hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor I've got quite a
big property portfolio now I've been
investing in property for over 10 years
can you believe it and I've also trained
tens of thousands of people also to
invest successfully in property so in
this video I wanted to talk about buy
refurbish refinance rent this is a
strategy that we call Berber or BRR BRR
I wouldn't call it and effectively it's
when you buy a house and rather than
leaving your money in avonlea just
buying a house put in twenty five
percent deposit in and then leaving your
money in and getting a return on
investment with the burst strategy by
refurbish we've announced rent you want
to buy the house but you buy cheap and
then you refurbish it and you push the
value up and then you refinance it pull
your money back out and then rent it out
and the idea of it is is that you take a
small pot of money and instead of
leaving it into a house you put it in
take it out put it in take it out put it
in take it out as many times as you can
to grow a property portfolio so in this
video I want to explain how that works
I'll explain what the strategy is and
then give you the pros and the cons for
doing this strategy compared to just
regular buy-to-let where you leave your
money in so firstly the great thing I
love about this strategy is if you're a
buyer refurbish refinance buyer you're
not going to buy it traditionally with a
mortgage so you're not going to get a
mortgage on the property combined with
your deposit you're going to instead
you're going to use something called
bridging finance
bridging finance is a short term loan
that's usually specifically used to buy
a property and the reason it's called a
bridging loan or bridging finance is
because the purpose of it is to bridge
the gap between your uten between you
buying a house and getting a mortgage so
instead of thinking down the line of
just I'm gonna just buy a house and get
a mortgage it's actually the opposite
you're gonna buy a house with cash using
a bridging finance loan and then you're
gonna push the value up
and then you're gonna get a mortgage
you're gonna get a mortgage a few months
after you've bought the house and we
call that kind of mortgage a remortgage
it's a refinance same thing and the
reason is called a remortgage is because
you're doing it afterwards so you're
getting a mortgage afterwards instead of
getting it upfront so this only works
okay if you can push the value of the
property up because if you can't it's
completely pointless if you buy a house
for a hundred grand with a bridging loan
and some of your own money and then you
spend 20 grand on the property and
ultimately you've put in 120 now but
then the new value of the property is
only 120 when you remortgage you're
gonna get a seventy five percent loan to
value against that 120 which is
pointless however if you buy a house for
a hundred grand spend 20 grand doing it
up and then the new value is 150 or 160
because every time you've spent a pound
on the refurb you've pushed the value up
by three pounds which is what you need
to do then when you refinance it you're
gonna you're gonna all the money that
you've got from the new mortgage you're
gonna be able to use on paying yourself
back and paying back the bridging loan
so if you do it properly the great thing
about it is it means that you're gonna
pull all your money out and then what
you're gonna do with that money you're
gonna use that money again to buy
another property to buy another property
to use apply another property so this is
how rich people tend to grow their
portfolios rather than working really
hard saving the big deposit and buying a
house saving a pretty positive Iying
house they don't work hard and save up
money what they do is they creatively
finance their deals doing things like
buy refurbish refinance rent another
great thing about buy with urban street
finance rent is because you'll buy them
for cash slash using your bridging loan
you can get the best kind of deals
because you're buying cash property
sellers like that it's attractive
you say look I'll buy the property but I
need to get a mortgage application I
need to get this and I need to get that
in their mind they're thinking that
could take time but it doesn't I'll bite
straight out cash using a bridging loan
you're in a position where you can get a
much cheaper
property also you're in a position where
you can buy properties that are earn
mortgageable so some properties if they
haven't got a kitchen or they haven't
got a working bathroom they're not
really habitable you can't get a
mortgage on these properties because the
banks won't lend on them so if you buy
those properties you can get them so
cheap with a bridging loan but item
really cheap then get a nice kitchen get
a nice bathroom push the value up
refinance afterwards it's a much smarter
way to buy a property so pros of doing
this strategy are that you can use the
same small pot of money again again
again again to grow your portfolio so if
you've got 50 grands you can potentially
build build up a whole portfolio of
10-15 houses if you paid your cards
right rather than just putting it down
in one house so that's the obvious Pro
the con is it's much harder work to
firstly find the type of deal that's
going to be able to work as a BRR deal
and secondly you have to rely on
builders you have to make sure that you
know what the end value is going to be
you have to be much smarter you have to
be more due diligence so more time
effort energy and knowledge is involved
in doing a Bible firmest refinance
versus just put your money into a
straightforward buy to let my advice
would be if you've got the time if
you've got the inclination and if you
want to grow your portfolio and expand
your net worth would be to learn to buy
refurbish we finance strategy I think
it's fabulous strategy it's something
that works very well now in 2020 because
because of the housing dip at them and
properties are going down we're in a
position where we can get very cheap
properties people are very motivated but
banks are still lending so the refinance
at the end there are a lot of lenders
that are still lending so I think it's a
great strategy
I'd probably rate it a nine out of 10 in
strategies let me know what you think
below in the comments of by refurbished
refinance rent as a property investment
strategy if you've got any questions or
thoughts comment them in the description
below I'm going to do another video soon
explaining a different property
investment strategy comment what
strategy you want to hear about next if
you enjoyed the video please don't
forget to subscribe I'm gonna be doing a
more videos like this with other
strategies so please do subscribe turn
the notification about on also if you
want to learn more about this strategy
if you're like I want to learn about buy
refurbish refinance rents and I've given
you enough information to get you
thinking and open your mind when you
want to actually do it then I would like
to invite you to a training session I'm
going to be running it is completely
free and it's online it's an online
webinar about buying refurbished
refinance rents so in the description
box below I'm going to leave a little
link and if you click on the link there
either been upcoming webinar or if
there's not you can leave your details
and then the next time we're running one
you will be the first to know when we're
gonna be running a free advanced
training session on this strategy don't
forget to subscribe right here subscribe
turn the notification bail on if you
want to learn more about HMOs you can
click on this video right here or you
can learn how to rent out your property
of maximum rent and I'll see you next
time